police in Maine are on the hunt for an
armed and dangerous suspect connected to
two shootings that officials say killed
18 people Wednesday night the massacre
in Lewiston Maine's second largest city
marked the country's deadliest mass
shooting in 2023 so far according to the
research group gun violence
archive here's how the two shootings
that sent shock waves through the rural
State
unfolded at 6:56 p.m. on Wednesday
police said they received a call of a
male shooter at the Justin Time
Recreation bowling alley in Lewiston
Maine shortly after at 7:08 p.m. police
said they received additional calls of
an active shooter at a restaurant called
schi roughly 4 miles away from the
bowling
alley around 8 p.m. authorities released
images on Facebook of the suspected
shooter main State Police issued a
shelter in place for local residents
urging them to stay inside their homes
with doors locked State Police later
identified 40-year-old Robert card of
Bowden Maine as the sole person of
interest in the shootings around 10 p.m.
State Police said in a social media post
that authorities located a vehicle
belonging to card at a nearby boat
launch in
Lisbon police are currently searching
for a Robert R card 44 of 1983 of Bowen
card is considered armed and dangerous
on Thursday residents in Lewiston and
nearby towns were told to shelter in
place as officers searched for card
police confirmed that seven people were
killed at just in time Recreation and
eight people were killed at schi three
people later died in the hospital a
White House spokesperson said President
Biden has been briefed and would
continue to receive
Updates this city did not deserve this
terrible assault on its citizens on its
peace of mind on its sense of
[Music]
security